hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer questions from
my form administrator GT who kicked off
a debate in our forms around the new
post that he put up around should you
allow blog comments on your blog or not
so his exact post was I was just reading
an article web pro news and one of the
subjects covered is whether or not you
should allow blog comments on your block
one point of view is that they're good
because it provides user feedback and
the opportunity to interact with
visitors the other point of view is our
comments add little value and can often
have a negative impact on your site a
Google engineer is quoted as saying that
blog comments may possibly be diluting
the quality score of a page so he's
wondering about it has to look into it
too much and he was one in our thoughts
should you allow block comments or not
so here's my take i do allow blog
comments and i do it two different ways
i'll share my experiences and hopefully
this can help everybody the first part
is i really believe that you should
allow blog comments on your site i like
it because it allows you to start
interacting with your customers and
people who are coming to your site and
they start interacting I'm more likely
to hang around the more likely to sign
up for your newsletter the more likely
to buy your products and services so you
want to encourage participation in
interaction because it makes it a little
more sticky ties into your brain and
makes me want to come back if there's no
ability to comment then they're less
likely to come back and less likely to
become a customer of your business so
you definitely want to encourage people
to participate in your business stay
longer on your website and be able to
take that next step if it's sign up for
news that are buying your product over
it is the second thing is I think it
provides a lot of valuable feedback for
you so it tells you which post you're
creating are getting a lot of response
it tells you people like the content
you're coming up with or not and people
might also offer other suggestions for
how you can make your blog better and as
businesses if we want to become better
entrepreneurs we need to make sure we're
listening to our customers listen to
your feedback and try to take those
advice that we get from them and and put
it into our business to make it better
so shutting off the ability of people to
tell us what they think I don't think
it's a really smart idea now the last
part is
you do run a blog and you are getting
comments it can also add a lot of
credibility to your website so when
people first visit a blog one of the
things you'll see is how many comments
are left on here and if it sees that
there's a lot of comments it looks like
it's an authority website and they're
more likely to read the content it to
come to the site and see if there's no
comments a lot of people thank God I
know if I want to trust this person or
not and they may take off and go to a
different site so if you do have a blog
with a lot of comments it can add a lot
of credibility which can help you with
new customers coming in and also with
media and partners and suppliers it
makes you look a little more respectable
so definitely try to encourage comments
now that being said you do need to
moderate them right you need to make
sure that its value I type of comments
that are being put into your blog posts
and useful information right so it's
okay to help this different point of
views but you have to make sure that
it's being added to the conversation
it's not just being spam so there are
some plugins you can use especially if
you're on a wordpress back-end to help
you moderate your comments but you
definitely have to make sure you're
looking out for them the second part is
if you're really worried about the
negative impact it might have the
quality of comments aren't great and you
want to make sure it's only your content
that's being indexed in Google another
option you can use is facebook comments
and some of the bigger blocks have moved
to trying facebook comments and
basically facebook gives you a plug-in
to allow people to leave comments the
facebook profile and it shows up on each
individual blog post and this is good in
the sense that you can still get
participation from your readers it
forces people to use their existing
facebook account so it's harder to post
anonymous posts you have to use your own
account and it might even get you a
little bit more exposure for your blog
post because when they do put a post on
it sends it up to their friends that hey
you know they just posted on this blog
their friends might be interested in
checking out the blog as well so it
might give you some back to exposure at
the same time it doesn't show up in your
HTML so the content of the the block
comments don't show up in your HTML so
Google doesn't crawl it so that can be
good or bad if you're worried about the
the quality score then facebook comments
is a great way to do it because it's not
going to show up in the code of your
site so it's google never get it
so GT I hope that helps everybody else
has been discussing in the farms I hope
you found that useful that's what I use
on my blog I'll use comments just like
any other wordpress blog and then on my
articles on the site will use facebook
comments so we've kind of split it up
between the two I love to hear what you
guys have to think if you want to leave
a comment below the video please do and
please give the video a thumbs up
encourages me to make more these types
of videos and hopefully you'll stay
tuned for the next episode